well my background comes from the FBI my
background was as an FBI investigator I
was an undercover operative um AKA a
ghost the idea was that we I could
follow you from sun up to sun down I
could investigate you see everything you
did every person you met count how many
times you tied your shoes or checked
your watch where you went I could even
listen to you sleep we were we were
these highly trained operatives who
would work fully undercover I never came
out of cover for all the time I was in
the FBI and um I learned those
investigative skills I was fighting uh
not only spies but terrorists here in
the United States um you know we bounced
between the two stopping the uh
Espionage attacks stopping the terrorist
attacks but but learning that deep level
of how to be an investigator how to find
the facts how to find the truth from the
[Music]
lies Eric O'Neal welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
with me I really really appreciate your
time thank you so much for being here
Michael it's good to be here and thanks
for giving me some time to tell my story
no no no Eric thank you for for spending
20 minutes educating me and everybody
else listening here so so this show is
all about leadership it's it's all about
the leader a lot of different elements
in leadership and and I'm always so
fascinated by how different people
experience and exert it in their own
lives and you're
spending a lot of time sharing you know
your story with with different audiences
both uh both through engagements and
actually speaking to them but also in
writing H whether it's through your
books or through your new newsletter
congratulations for that thank you and
by the way if we want to get to the
newsletter what what how do we do that
well you can hit you can get to it
directly from my website it's www. Eric
oil.net and right at the top there's a
link to you know subscribe to my news
letter I I do it once a week it's
completely free I talk about all the
things you need to know in spies lies
and cyber crime so it's always really
cool present and important information
so spies lies in cyber Crim that's right
at least two of them are my favorite
things in the world maybe all three but
but but Eric what what does that
actually mean well think about the way
that attacks have evolved and when I
talk about attacks the number one way
that anyone steals anyone anything today
is through a Cyber attack it's through
some sort of penetration of a computer
system because data drives everything in
my uh book my new book that's coming out
the invisible threat it's coming out
this year 2025 we're already there uh I
talk about how data is so critical and I
say that data is now the currency of our
lives and you think about it it is I
mean money now is even data and all of
the things that are important to a
business is your data um your employees
but then your data is is so critical and
because that data is accessible because
virtually every system now is attached
to the Internet it's vulnerable and so
attackers when I say attackers I'm
talking about spies or cyber criminals
are desperate to get it that is what
they do that is their entire job and
reason for being so protecting that data
becomes incredibly important I wanted to
write a newsletter that goes along with
the books that I write the thought
leadership that I provide and the things
that I say on stage and because I'm a
Storyteller I always start with a story
but it's a story about a Cyber attack or
an Espionage event some sort of lie that
got someone to give up their data and uh
usually ends up in some sort of
catastrophic loss with a little bit of
humor thrown in too I don't like to talk
you know about these things with too
much Doom and Gloom but they're
important lessons that people have to
learn and you know you read my stuff you
end up being more protected because you
can see the scam before it hits you yeah
well I I think the stories are are
the stories that are going to get
written in the upcoming months and years
I think are going to be Beyond a fiction
level uh from the sophistication and the
excitement ER the company that I that I
run Clarity we deal with deep fixes deep
fixes are all about deception and lies
and how to extort not only data but how
to take to to do things sometimes
without the other person even knowing
that they were scammed until they until
they actually learn about it from the
person they thought they were talking
talking to so Eric tell me tell me about
you know some of these examples maybe
even just one key one that that you that
comes to mind just that we can get into
your your mindset into what you mean by
by these types of attacks well here here
you go let's let's stick with deep fakes
you raised it AI deep fakes fascinate me
I think that AI is one of the biggest
disruptors and Game Changers that we've
ever seen since the Advent of the
internet is changing the way that we
work it's going to change the future of
every from medicine to Legal practice to
think of any kind of industry that deal
deals with manipulating data or
information um it's even if you apply AI
to robotics going to change how we work
and how we live and how we age uh it's
changing medicine at an extreme rate but
it is also an incredible tool for the
bad guys and when I'm talking about them
I'm usually talking about cyber
criminals who have learned to exploit AI
in very innovative and clever ways to do
what we call in cyber security social
engineering people into believing that
what they see is true in other words
Michael believing the LIE right and
here's a great example I highlight a
case in my upcoming book uh about a
multinational corporation that's out of
the UK that has a branch in Hong Kong
and a Financial Manager sitting in the
branch in Hong Kong receives an email
from the CFO in the UK now most people
who hear this story think okay it's your
typical business email compromise the
email address has been compromised and
then the attacker send an email from a p
position and Authority either the CEO or
the CFO saying send this wire
immediately if you don't we're going to
lose the deal and you're going to get
fired and then people do it there is
it's something like $49 billion last
year in the amount of money that was
lost just with that scheme but these
attackers are way more clever because
organizations are now training this away
you know the CFO will never send you an
email saying send a wire you know you
call him directly the email is more
clever than that it says join a zoom
meeting and so he he thinks this is my
boss telling me to join a meeting he
straightens his tie and jumps on the
video conference and he sees the CFO he
sees two people he recognizes from
finance and then two people he doesn't
recognize and the CFO in the meeting
says would everyone please introduce
thems and they do and he learns the two
people he doesn't recognize are Partners
on a brand new deal this is an
Architecture Firm it's going to be this
big new deal they need to start working
together and the CFL abruptly cancels
the call now the emails start asking him
to send wires and he does 15 different
wires to five different banks in Hong
Kong to the tune of $25 million before
he starts to feel uneasy about it and he
calls the cfo's office in the UK and
they've never heard of him or the wires
the entire thing was this stage deep
fake event all of the avatars he was
seeing in this conference were were
created using very hyperrealistic deep
fakes that move and say exactly what the
attacker wants them to say and so it
created that element of trust because we
believe our eyes we believe what we see
so then they could be using the more
traditional business email compromise
email attack and he just believed it
because he already had that level of
verification so when we can't even see
when we can't even believe what we see
going into this new future with AI uh
trust becomes the most valuable thing on
earth even more valuable than data
because you can't even trust your data
it becomes
useless how did you get into the the
world of trust and the world of the
deception FBI H how how do how does you
how did your journey start well my
background comes from the FBI my
background was as an FBI investigator I
was an undercover operative um AKA a
ghost the idea was that we I could
follow you from sun up to sun down I
could investigate you see everything you
did every person you met count how many
times you tied your shoes or checked
your watch where you went I could even
listen to you sleep we were we were
these highly trained operatives who
would work fully undercover I never came
out of cover for all the time I was in
the FBI and um I learned those
investigative skills I was fighting uh
not only spies but terrorists here in
the United States um you know you bounce
between the two stopping the uh
Espionage attacks stopping the terrorist
attacks but but learning that deep level
of how to be an investigator how to find
the facts how to find the truth from the
lies and after I left the FBI when I
practiced law I worked in National
Security Law for a while but I always
remembered what I did in the FBI and so
started a company called The Georgetown
group group about 5 years after I left
the FBI that does exactly that empowers
trust and what we do is we look for the
lie we look for the deception we look
for the uh the trick or the scam um in
in all of the dealings that are that our
uh clients are handling whether it's a
major acquisition or a big
litigation beyond that I started
thinking
about what what is Counter Intelligence
right the sence of countering the goals
of some foreign usually some foreign
entity that wants to do you wrong but it
can also apply to cyber security and so
using a background in Tech and cyber I
started applying FBI Counter
Intelligence techniques to cyber
security and working with the major
cyber security companies to help bring
Counter Intelligence to the technology
and it's uh it's been a really fun ride
helping inform the technology helping
lead the the discussion in cyber
security and uh this last year we just
started a new company called NEX aure
that does cyber security advisory
services and continues to do a lot of
that work that I've been doing in
incredible so what is it like for you
now to transition from working you know
very much in the physical world you very
dedicated you you are the you are the
security and you are the intelligence to
then understanding it on a greater scale
and understanding the different concept
Tru of what makes up it sounds you
probably dealt with Incredible things
you know when you're dealing with in the
legal space with National Security and
to the Georgetown group to now working
with cyber security firms how how is
that progression changed the way that
you think through you know your
contribution and the way that you are
putting your own your own effort and
impact into the world well the world has
changed you know and then I you know my
book
uh The Invisible Threat I talk about how
you know that that event we don't talk
about right that that thing that
happened a few years ago that nobody
says anymore that just disappeared you
know you don't see movies about it no
one talks about it remember covid-19 the
pandemic it's like shouting Voldemort in
Harry Potter um but it happened and it
changed us and sometimes I think we
forgot how much it changed us I work
from home now I mean I'm an entrepreneur
I run my own businesses we don't have an
office office anywhere I mean my
partners are all over the country and
some in different places in the world it
makes no sense for us to have an office
other than it would be nice you know to
to occasionally leave the house and go
somewhere where I
work most organizations are going that
way and there's this tension now in fact
in where the big organizations that have
these very expensive office spaces you
know on um on K Street in DC or you know
near Time Square or wherever want to
bring their employees back just to jum
justify the rent they're paying but for
the most part the way that we work the
way that we consume information the way
that we live the way that we play has
changed and it's become it's a very
disassociated world that gives an
amazing Avenue for any kind of cyber
attacker to insert themselves because if
you're doing all of your work from
wherever you are it's easier to trick
you it's easier to fool you scam you
social engineer you so when I'm looking
at how we protect information how we
protect people I've been out of the
physical space for a long time I'm in
this world of data and data is funable
it moves around it can be you can access
it from wherever you are that's the way
the world has isn't going the world has
become it's evolved already you're
seeing companies that don't care about
borders when they hire you why hire
someone um you know right down the
street if you can get someone who's
better and cheaper in another country
and so you're seeing this change in this
globalization of how we even conduct
employment there there really are no B
borders to data and so you need to make
sure that you're protecting in a way
that um accepts
that where where do you see that we're
extremely succeeding in versus where
we're have significant gaps
today yeah we're doing a great job of
collaboration I mean just what we're
doing right here Michael and you're
running a
podcast uh and I don't have to come to
your Studio you
know five years ago you'd be footing the
bill for me to fly to your studio and
sit down with you but now you know
anyone can do this anyone who has a good
idea anybody who has um some Innovative
idea can talk to people and create this
content in the in the world of business
this is happening as well as we meet
with people all over the world without
having to get on a on a fast plane and
and spend you know three nights hotel
Now the default is a video meeting and I
have clients I might have met once in
person you know but most of our
conversations are just like this we're
doing that very well the tools to
collaborate are excellent and expressing
thems in new and innovative ways that
some people are leveraging and some
people are just learning like for
example AI why would anyone ever take
notes again when you can use an AI
notetaker um ai ai makes an amazing
editor AI can make you think about
things differently it can help you move
that Innovative process along you can
ask it questions it can be your sounding
board it can be your business colleague
or your executive assistant that's what
we're doing really well now what aren't
we doing so well we aren't really doing
well in protecting the things that
matter one of the biggest things I like
to talk about is critical infrastructure
if you think of your lights and your
power and your water and your Wastewater
your telecommunication sector I mean our
our in the United States here the four
of the five major telecom companies were
breached by China for months where uh
the Chinese government could listen into
calls and read texts and we had no idea
and they were stealing all of the meta
data so they could see what were the
most interesting calls to cherry-pick
what they listened to I mean that's
Troublesome uh we we have volt Typhoon
from uh China and sandworm which is an
attack group from Russia who have been
embedded thems in the pH in the lights
and power critical infrastructure here
in the United States for some time and
in other places in the west I'm very
worried about a catastrophic attack
because the future of warfare is going
to be majority cyber and we need to do a
much better job we I mean particularly
the West has to do a much better job at
protecting those critical infrastructure
sectors that are so important to have a
to allow us to have safe and happy
lives I I think that's all I that all
really hits home and and really
resonates you know I we have a a great
friend of mine runs a cyber security
firm called
Clarity and it's all about you know iot
and critical infrastructure and how do
you and how do you think about defending
these types of infrastructures in in in
the in the world that we're moving in
and I think that's pretty I think that's
that it's incredibly impressive um and
while and with that there's incredible
gaps that we're saying you know I'm
saying the gaps that we have in in the
infrastructure that we have to secure
even real-time communication like we're
doing right now as it comes to the
notion of deep fakes and and going back
to the story that you mentioned it's
it's not just one incident it's a it's
actually that anecdote repeats itself
cons quite consistently H throughout
many different organizations um and and
especially those that I've I don't think
I've come across one organization I've
spoken to that hasn't had some some
attempt at least going back Eric to your
journey and and the the different things
you've done you've you've been in
leadership positions throughout pretty
much everything you've done and it
sounds like you you've brought the
entrepreneurial mindset and you know and
a leadership mindset to everything that
you did do you know to attribute what
what's been sort of the source the main
driver for you to to keep on doing this
and to to be at the Forefront in these
different Endeavors whatever they may be
yeah I I've put quite a bit of thought
into this I think I'm never happy to
just settle into something that I do
well and just do it right I I think I've
always felt like I I need to see what
the next thing is what's over the next
Horizon to really engage myself and
excite myself when I speak to you know
kids in high school or um or in college
what I always tell them is you need to
find something that you want to do and
that you're going to enjoy and is going
to make you want to get up in the
morning and go achieve learn experience
if you don't you're going to be bored
and you're going to be miserable because
we spend most of our time at work so do
something you love do something that
you're passionate about do something
that excites you and you know that's
that's been the test of my career it's
always been looking at this next thing
where is what's Over the Horizon that I
can tackle that I can be ahead of
everybody else what really interesting
thing can I bring onto a stage and
completely entertain and inform Inspire
an audience for an hour keynote uh where
nobody's looking at their phone and
nobody leaves their seat these are the
things that make me happy these are the
things that uh I think give some benefit
to others and uh that's what I'm all
about Eric thank you so much for being
here this is such a pleasure and and
insightful and interesting and I really
appreciate your time and your insights h
so thank you so much for joining me here
yeah Michael thank you for the
discussion I think the 20 minute format
is a brilliant idea and I appreciate
giving some time 20 exact minutes to
tell my story thank you so much Eric
thank you